our next guest a former University of
Minnesota quarterback is the most recent
NFL player to throw an interception and
catch an interception in the same game
is that a good record I don't know he
went on to become a successful head
coach with Tampa and Indianapolis many
young coaches consider him an influence
and a mentor in his current profession
broadcasting he's often cited me as his
influencer it may be that I'm the
greatest broadcaster of all time the
Tony Dungy broadcasting or something
like that please welcome our good friend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but Urlacher don't know I'm not gonna
embarrass me there's not enough plane
I'm not enough footage of you playing to
be able to find plays to embarrass you
coach Continental Tire Coach's Corner
the exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick
show no matter where you drive or what
you drive Continental designs tires for
what you do for more information there's
a Continental Tire dot-com
was there ever it was there a moment
when you played with the Steelers when
you're when you're on the field and you
go this isn't for me
like I I don't know if I can I want to
do this as a career
yeah my my rookie year I converted from
quarterback had never played defense
before I'm out there playing against all
these guys and making mistake after
mistake and I made a big mistake in the
red zone cleveland scores a touchdown
bud Carson our defensive coordinator
says you're trying to get me fired he
said but before I let chuck fire me I'm
firing you and I thought yeah this might
not be a great profession but the coach
snow came over and said you know put his
arm around what were you what were you
looking at what were you thinking didn't
we practice the why is it coaches yell
at players because you get frustrated
because you know it and you think they
should know it and you're over there
watching and has happened in slow motion
and they're out there and it's happened
a thousand miles an hour and after the
fact you know it as as I walked off the
field I said I know what call I was
supposed to make I know what I was
supposed to do I just then I couldn't do
it but just yelling he'll know it does
okay it doesn't and I learned that from
coach Noll so I didn't yell it guys most
often because they they understand they
made a mistake they don't need to know
hey you made a mistake
yeah they just need how to fix it the
next I use that philosophy with my kids
if I give them the silent treatment
after something Bad's happen that sinks
in far more than if you say something to
them so I don't know if that happens
yes boy use it with other people than
just your kids Dan okay times when I've
done that to the den s where I I go
silent I go cold on them and the message
sent and the one person who would affect
the most Todd fritz I get very sensitive
oh my I almost rather you screaming when
you do the blow-off and like it like
they do it like a ghost thing you look
not even visible that's horrible
did you ever have a player like fritzy
can't say that I had I did have some
sensitive could you yell at Peyton not
really it was an effective way to coach
him Marvin Harrison was the same way I
mean I remember my first we were playing
the Patriots actually and I made it I
said tile I was looking forward to
covering you and and he didn't talk to
me for two days and then he came in my
office on Friday and he said you know I
don't joke about the game okay I
understand now and then we understood
yeah now why does he thought you were
making something up or you liked I was
really wants to play against you because
he doesn't think you're very good and I
was just making a joke and Marvin said
hey I joke about a lot of things but not
about football you were a defensive
coordinator so if I said be a defensive
coordinator you're the Rams you're Wade
Phillips so what do you want to do on
Sunday Rodney and we've been on together
for nine years and Rodney always says
that you have to get pressure up the
middle against Tom but you can't blitz
to do it if you have to blitz like Brian
said he'll see it he'll know where it's
going to he'll get rid of the ball so
you have to get pressure and you have to
understand it's not gonna come from
Aaron Donald because Bill Belichick's
thing is he's gonna take the most
important weapon away and make the other
guys beat you so if I'm Wade Phillips
I've gone to in dominance two and said
you know what if we're gonna win the
Super Bowl you have to be the MVP on
Sunday and you better be ready to play
you're gonna get single blocked and you
got to cause havoc the whole time that
they follow you got to come off the edge
and you got to get there one or two
times we got to play man coverage make
him hold the ball a little bit and you
two guys have to win the game
and that's my philosophy it feels like
that when the Patriots have lost a big
game you know the Giants in the Super
Bowl had pressure up the middle the
Ravens could bring pressure up the
middle and we set it on the pregame when
we had the Giants I said Justin Tuck
will have a chance to be the MVP because
they're gonna make sure Michael Strahan
doesn't beat them and those inside
rushes are gonna have one-on-ones and
Justin Tuck was huge that day I what are
the Patriots do against a young
quarterback and a very talented running
back they will mix things up and they'll
play something that they maybe haven't
played all year and Sean McVeigh and
Jared Goff we're gonna have to say okay
what is this okay what do we have what
works against it and make those
adjustments we had the same thing in the
championship game in O six when we went
to the Super Bowl we got down 21 3 ok
here's what they're doing here's the
coverage now we're just we scored 32 in
the second half last week Kansas City
scored 31 in the second half once they
figured out you don't know what it's
going to be and you got to be able to
just quick I think Sean McVeigh and Gulf
it's how quickly can they figure it out
and counteract
when you look at quarterbacks it's hard
to say okay this quarterbacks better
than this quarterback because you played
in an era you coached against Joe
Montana Steve Young you mean we can
Brett Favre we can pin you had Peyton of
course but when it comes to Brady are we
gonna hold losses again like LeBron we
hold losses in the finals against him
you know as opposed to how many times
Michael got there six times what about
all the times he didn't get there
where is Montana went there for time
what about all the other times here's
Brady and LeBron getting all in there
year after year after year it's
unbelievable how hard it is to do that
to get to the championship game to win
it and get to the Super Bowl nine times
is it's unheard of unfathomable when did
you realize that Brady was better than
Peyton or would be viewed better than
Peyton well the the longevity and
winning and getting there but like you
say you really can't compare people
they're mad at me in New England because
of the way I rank things but you said
Joe Montana Elway those guys
you know we could hit them in the knee
we could hit them in the head we could
hit their receivers coming across the
middle and it was a different game so
how would those guys function now Moreno
would be the one yeah I don't think you
guess they wouldn't be fair with these
rules I agree if I take Peyton off the
board and you can start your team with
any quarterback all time
current rules I add those mobile
quarterbacks it's so difficult and
that's the way I put John Elway Aaron
Rodgers those guys who can when you
blitz them or when you can get pressure
you gotta front for like the Rams and
you can't block them John Elway could
still make plays and run around and
throw the ball back 60 yards across
field you know those mobile guys to me
that that's a different element I think
Elwes the greatest quarterback of all
time but I look at it differently
because he he didn't have all-pro
offensive guys I think he had Gary
Zimmerman a tackle and that was it but
there were times when you needed to win
you knew he was going to win the game
for you then he finally got some help
with Shannon Sharpe and Terrell Davis
then he won a couple of Super Bowls but
those first three I didn't think that
offense was very good and their defense
was know and they were supposed to be
built on defense and they got overmatch
but we hold those losses like the
Buffalo Bills in the Minnesota Vikings
when you lose a Super Bowl it's like
your bums but it but you got to the
Super Bowl and and we don't give credit
to the Buffalo Bills right I agree John
Elway was so good
I'm defensive backfield coach in Kansas
City Marty Schottenheimer we're up four
points it's fourth down and ten and
Marty goes for it so what are you doing
coach he said I'm not punting the ball
back to John Elway you guys can't stop
him did you make it we did Oh Rob Thomas
caught a ball and we won the game
and we didn't have to defend that
two-minute drive and we celebrated what
do we do in the offseason I know that we
like to revamp whenever there's
controversy let's start with overtime
you know let me start before that was
something you said let's start with
full-time officials you know get those
guys working all the time get them in on
Mondays all hundred and 25 of them to
look at every play this is how we're
gonna call it this is how we're not
going to call it make it full-time
and then in the playoffs keep the
officials together if that was a crew
yeah when that happened two other guys
would have run and they was there you
know what right hey I saw this you got
it we missed it this is the flag but
because hey I don't know this guy he's
supposed to be the best you know
crews need to be together yeah
egos get in the way a little bit I'm
familiarity yeah you know
okay so overdoing it over times okay
I like overtime the way it is okay I'm a
defensive minded coach we kick off I
need to be able to hold you to a field
goal if you're gonna drive it down 14
plays and score then we deserve to lose
the game I would on these rules I would
want to kick off stop the other team
maybe hold them to a field goal at least
we know what we need the second time
around all right as far as to play the
non call how do we ensure that that
doesn't happen
it's going to happen okay get used to it
get over it I was a student at the
University of Minnesota Drew Pearson
pushed off on Nate Wright in 1975 okay
he pushed off and they scored it happens
okay I don't know who are you over it I
am over okay all right I was mad I was
19 years old I was made for a year but
it's not gonna change the people in
Oakland still tell me Frenchy Fuqua hit
the ball and it shouldn't have happened
in the binocular section 40 years they
you know and you would talk about it and
it's fine Bertie Manuel caught the ball
okay we didn't go to the Super Bowl I'm
like Drew Brees we didn't go how'd it
over how does the Tuck rule get called
like how does that play get called do
you do you think it's because of this
it's an overreaction to something that
happens we try to fix it and then you
don't understand that's unintended
consequences from something he wasn't
tucking the ball charles woodson hitch
Brady in you go
how's that not a fumble somebody fumbled
the ball and they should have called it
this way should have called an
incomplete pass so they try to make a
black-and-white rule count this whole
catch no catch thing Dez Bryant and Zach
Ertz going
it started with Calvin Johnson Calvin's
we saw it with and Calvin Johnson
catches the ball he's celebrating and he
had the ball for 10 minutes no I know
and they called it incomplete and then
to justify that they had to come up with
this rule that now we've got all these
no catches for the next 10 years and
it's overreaction to a bad call so we
can't overreact to this here's here's
our question you can have Julian Edelman
career or Calvin Johnson I'm probably
taking Julian Edelman because I'm gonna
go to superb okay yeah I agree because
at first you go with Calvin's one of the
greatest athletes who's ever played that
position but the only highlight he has
that we show is the touchdown that was
overturned so there's no I mean Edelman
you can't write the history of the NFL
without Julian Edelman yeah because of
those great catches that catch against
the Falcons in the Super Bowl you know
that hit he took against kam chancellor
in the Seattle game like I would take
Edelman my bank accounts not gonna be as
user friendly but I would take his cover
I'm gonna give you a question then do
you want to be Barry Sanders or Matthews
later
I'll take Barry soon you don't care
about the Superbowl ring not not okay if
I said Emmitt Smith or Barry saying no
no that's the guy who's what Marcus
Allen or Barry Sanders yeah a little
return volley there you never get let me
get that by the way you didn't answer
yet
Marcus Allen supalen yeah Tony's got a
new book it's called the soul of a team
in which it's a team building and
getting people to work together for a
common goal
fictional football team and they're
struggling so Tony is hired as a
consultant to get them on the right
track this isn't like the story the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers is it
well we're gonna let you think about who
it might be so like when I'm consulting
and they offer us a wide receiver who
doesn't want to play for his team you
can get is that also the Steelers with
Antonia brown could it be the Jets and
Keyshawn Johnson could it be tio we kind
of leave that up in the air but we just
make the principle that's why it has to
be fictional Toni joins us Continental
Tire Coaches Corner for more information
on Continental Tire no matter what you
drive where you drive visit Continental
Tire calm it's always great to see my
buddy let's take a break
Kyler Murray will join us wait to meet
him yeah what would you tell him to do
follow your heart follow your heart yeah
I tried to tell Charlie Ward to play
football
think he'd a follow for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]